[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo zusammen und willkommen zu einem
neuen Fall ich bin Mirco und ich bin
Toni hi und bevor wir loslegen ein
kleiner schautout an unseren Hörer Udo
denn er hat uns den heutigen Fall
vorgeschlagen vielen Dank dafür und
liebe Grüße
Toni hier bei Tatort Deutschland hatten
wir schon den Fall einer Erpressung mit
dem höchsten Lösegeld der deutschen
Kriminalgeschichte für den heutigen Fall
haben wir uns vielleicht die
spektakulärste Erpressung vorgenommen
und diesmal mussten wir uns besonders
lang einlesen allerdings es gibt ein
davor ein währenddessen und ein langes
danach es gibt abenteuerliche
Apparaturen Hundehaufen und
fahrradstürze aber wir beginnen unsere
Geschichte in einer Berliner Grundschule
im Jahr 1998 oder 99
wenn der Kleine Christian über den
Pausenhof rennt rufen ihn die anderen
manchmal Donald und lachen denn
Christians Vater hat sich den Spitznamen
Dagobert gegeben
die Mitschüler finden diese Geschichte
cool aber Christian wäre lieber ein ganz
normaler Junge als Christian vier Jahre
alt war stimmten bewaffnete Polizisten
in das graue Einfamilienhaus in Berlin
Mariendorf und durchsuchten Zimmer für
Zimmer wenn er jetzt sein Vater sehen
will muss er ihn im Gefängnis besuchen
seine Mutter Etna hat sich längst von
ihrem Mann getrennt nach sechs Jahren
konnte Christian seinen Vater draußen
Wiedersehen er wurde wegen guter Führung
vorzeitig entlassen Vater und Sohn gehen
ins Museum Eis essen oder spazieren
einfach durch den Wald später wird
Christian sagen dass dies die schönste
Zeit seines Lebens war wir verabschieden
uns jetzt erstmal von Christian und
Reisen in die Zeit vor seiner Geburt ins
Jahr 1988
am 10 Mai wird in Berliner Kaufhaus des
Westens eine Rohrbombe entdeckt die
nicht explodiert ist ein anonymer
Erpresser fordert 500.000 Mark sonst
würde etwas Schlimmes passieren aber die
Geldübergabe scheitert nur fünf Tage
später der nächste Schlag am 25 Mai
explodiert im KaDeWe tatsächlich eine
Rohrbombe es ist mitten in der Nacht
deshalb wird niemand verletzt aber der
Schaden ist immens und beläuft sich auf
250.000 Mark diesmal gelingt die
Übergabe das Geldpaket werfen Polizisten
aus einer fahrenden S-Bahn der Täter
kann mit dem Geld fliehen und lebt
offenbar einige Jahre gut von der Beute
denn es bleibt still um den Erpresser
erstmal am 13 Juni 1992 sitzt der
Hamburger Chef Ermittler Michael der
Leki mit seinen Kollegen in der
morgendlichen Besprechung als die
Meldung kommt
in der Porzellanabteilung von Karstadt
an der Mönckebergstraße ist vergangene
Nacht um 1 Uhr eine Rohrbombe
hochgegangen niemand wurde verletzt aber
der Schaden ist gewaltig zwei Tage
später bekommt Karstadt Post ein
Erpresser fordert eine Million Mark in
tausend an was jetzt folgt ist eine
Serie von Bombenanschlägen und eine
Serie von gescheiterten Geldübergaben zu
den Anschlägen wir starten in Bremen am
09 september 1992 wird im dortigen
karstadthaus nachts eine Brandbombe
gezündet der Wasserschaden durch die
Sprinkleranlage beträgt 6 Millionen
D-Mark Hannover eine Woche später
detoniert eine Bombe während der
Öffnungszeiten in einem Aufzug es wird
niemand verletzt Magdeburg 3 november
1992 ein Brandsatz in einem Abstellraum
geringer Schaden keine Verletzten
Bielefeld 19 Mai 1993 nächtliche
Explosion Berlin 6 dezember 1993 der
Nikolaustag eine Rohrbombe explodiert
während der Öffnungszeiten
mehrere Kunden erleiden ein Knalltrauma
zwischen diesen Anschlägen versucht der
anonyme Erpresser an sein Geld zu kommen
eine Million mag soll Karstadt ja
ursprünglich zahlen weil die
Geldübergaben aber mehrmals scheitern
erhöht der Täter auf 1,4 Millionen seine
Zahlungsbereitschaft soll der
kaufhauskonzern mit einer Anzeige in der
Lokalpresse signalisieren der
verabredete Text Onkel Dagobert grüßt
seine Neffen die Medien nennen den
Erpresser von nun an Dagobert Dagobert
ist kreativ und technisch sehr versiert
bei den geplanten Geldübergaben gibt er
jeweils Anweisungen durch Telefonanrufe
er benutzt dazu einen bestimmen
Verzerrer die vorher verabredeten Anrufe
kam von Telefonzellen deshalb lässt die
Berliner Polizei einmal 1.100 Apparate
überwachen ein anderes mal knapp 4000
aber Dagobert geht nicht in die Falle am
14 August 1992 weist der Erpresser die
Polizei an das Geld in einer Apparatur
an einem Zug zu stecken das Gerät ist
mit Saugnäpfen ausgestattet und hält so
außen am intercity-kette Kollwitz von
Hamburg nach Berlin
die Polizei geht davon aus dass eine
Zeitschaltuhr den Abwurf auslösen würde
aber das geschieht per Funk der Täter
trickst die Ermittler so zwar aus aber
statt Geld sind nur Papierschnipsel in
dem Paket im Oktober 92 soll Geld aus
einem Zug am S-Bahnhof
Berlin-Charlottenburg abgeworfen werden
der Erpresser fühlt sich aber beobachtet
und flieht mit dem Fahrrad ein BKA
Beamter ihn an und stürzt dabei selbst
angeblich rutschte er auf einem
Hundehaufen aus
der Erpresser entkommt und das Geld wird
nicht übergeben im Mai 1993 lässt die
Polizei Filialen des Elektronikmarktes
Conrad überwachen sie vermutet zurecht
dass der Erpresser dort Bauteile für
seine Apparate kauft um ein Haar wird
der geschnappt er entkommt durch einen
Seitenausgang im April 1993 soll Geld in
eine Kiste mit Streugut in Berlin
gesteckt werden der Erpresser hat die
Stelle zuvor aber tagelang präpariert
das ist ziemlich genial er hat sich als
Bauarbeiter verkleidet und die Kiste
über einen unterirdischen Schacht
geschoben als dann eine Tüte oben
reingesteckt wird bekommt er sie wie
geplant unterirdisch in den Schacht
gezogen aber auch diesmal ist statt Geld
wieder nur ein Haufen Papierschnipsel
drin im Januar 1994 präsentiert Tüftler
Dagobert seine nächste Idee und zwar auf
einem stillgelegten Gleis in Berlin
Charlottenburg mit Hilfe einer
aufgebauten mini-lore soll das Geld zum
erpressa gelangen 30 Meter vor dem Ziel
kippt die Lore aus dem Gleis der
Erpresser traut sich nicht die Tasche zu
holen und entkommt ohne das Geld dabei
war zum ersten Mal wirklich Geld bei
diesem Übergabe versucht dabei hätte das
mal gewusst aber ich muss sagen wirklich
großes Lob an diese Kreativität also
kann man nicht sagen dass für mich auch
hart für das Geld arbeiten würde
der Hamburger Chef Ermittler da Leki hat
sich mittlerweile längst Verstärkung
geholt die Polizeipsychologin Claudia
Brockmann erstellt ein Profil von
Dagobert und die Telefonate mit dem
Erpresser führt der ehemalige sek-chef
Klaus Springborn er gibt sich als
Karstadt Mitarbeiter aus und gewinnt mit
seiner tiefen sympathischen Stimme das
Vertrauen von Dagobert wie Bild später
zusammenfasst hat im Frühjahr 1994 der
Anfang vom Ende begonnen 19 April 19 94
Dagobert spricht 3 Minuten lang mit
lka-mann Springborn als Fahnder die
Telefonzelle erreichen ist der Erpresser
weg aber ein Zeuge gibt der Polizei eine
genaue Beschreibung danach wird eine
Phantomzeichnung erstellt einen Tag
später am 20 April 1994 Polizisten
beobachten einen Mann auf den die
Beschreibung passt er fährt ein Mietauto
und darin ist ein Klapprad die Adresse
des Fahrers wird ermittelt und
Kriminalisten gegen sich auf die Lauer
22 April 1994
Dagobert ruft aus einer Telefonzelle
nahe seiner Wohnung bei Klaus Springborn
an knapp drei Minuten dauert das
Gespräch als er das Haus verlässt stehen
da zwei Beamte in Zivil
er klingt irgendwie erleichtert als er
sagt ja ich bin Dagobert
Werbung Stefan ja ich weiß ja dass du
hin und wieder eine kleine Sportwette
abschließt richtig ja eine kleine ich
muss sagen das mache ich tatsächlich
ganz gerne vor allem wenn es besonders
spannende Spiele gibt bei denen es um
was geht dann kennst du ja sicherlich
Neo Bett oder na klar das ist doch der
Sportwettenanbieter bei dem Laura
Wontorra Markenbotschafterin ist genau
den Spot mit ihr habe ich auch schon mal
im Fernsehen gesehen ach und wusstest du
Anna das Neo Bett einer der ersten
Wettanbieter mit deutscher Lizenz ist
die wurde vor kurzem erst wieder um 5
Jahre verlängert nein aber jetzt weiß
ich tja und ich habe sogar was für dich
und für euch wenn ihr Neo Bett auch
besser kennenlernen wollt und zwar 10 €
wird Guthaben für Neukunden mit dem Code
Podcast 10 als Zahl auf Neo bett.de ich
wiederhole mit dem Code Podcast 10 10
als Zahl auf neo-bett.de also einfach
bei der Registrierung auf neo-bett.de
den Code Podcast 10 eingeben zehn als
Zahl und sofort landen zehn Euro ohne
Einzahlung auf dem bettkonto Bett Bro
musst du sein Konditionen gelten Spiel
Teilnahme ab 18 glücksspiel kann süchtig
machen offiziell die zensierter
wettpartner white listet Hilfe unter
bzga.de
Werbung Ende
also bis hierhin muss ich sagen ist das
wirklich ein faszinierender Fall vor
allem weil er so kreativ ist ich muss
sagen das ist so genial mit diesem
Schacht also da muss man auch erstmal
drauf kommen und auch diese Dreistigkeit
sich dann als Bauarbeiter zu verkleiden
etc das ist schon ziemlich tricky was er
sich da aus gedacht hat was der Mann
aber alles angesteckt hat und auch
hingekriegt hat
schwierig also bei aller Bewunderung
auch ziemlich gefährlich und das alles
nur um mein Geld zu kommen und ich
glaube was dem Ganzen die Krone aufsetzt
ist einfach dass er Dagobert heißt sein
Spitzname ist Dagobert dieser Fall ist
prädestiniert dafür Bewunderung
hervorzurufen der Toni da hast du
vollkommen recht das ist wirklich
beeindruckend und in der Öffentlichkeit
der schwanger auch schon immer so etwas
wie Bewunderung mit ja man hat über den
Fall geschmunzelt aber abgesehen davon
war es natürlich hoch gefährlich was der
Mann da gemacht hat und war nichts
anderes als
Rubbellose Erpressung und das ist
natürlich strafbar genau die Polizei hat
ihn ja dann auch mitgenommen und seinen
Namen rausgefunden Dagobert hat jetzt
für alle ein bürgerlichen Namen Arno
Martin Franz Funke und damit bekommt er
auch einen Lebenslauf Funke wird am 14
märz 1950 in Berlin geboren und wächst
im Stadtteil Rudow auf als Kind malt er
gerne mit 19 schließt er eine Ausbildung
als Schilder und lichtreklame-macher ab
Funke wird beruflich betrachtet eine Art
Nomade er arbeitet als Schildermaler DJ
Fahrer für eine getränkefirma und
Bauhelfer er versucht sich als Fotograf
und jobt schließlich als Lackierer in
einer Autowerkstatt die giftigen Dämpfe
sorgen für konzentrations- und
Gedächtnisstörungen er heiratet eine
Frau von den Philippinen Entner von ihr
haben wir am Anfang schon gehört
mit ihr bekommt er 1991 Sohn Christian
und zu dieser Zeit da lebt er schon
längst von dem Geld der kdw-erpressung
Etna weiß aber von all dem nichts und
auch nicht von den späteren Taten sein
aufregendes Leben tarnt Funke 22 Monate
lang in der kleinen bürgerlichen Idylle
von Berlin Mariendorf der gelernte
Schildermaler spielt den netten Nachbarn
bei dem nachtflagge das Licht brannte
und der gern ein Bier im Goldenen Horn
trank dieser Arno Funke wird in Berlin
am 14 Juni 1996 in zweiter Instanz zu
neun Jahren Haft verurteilt er schreibt
in der Haft seine Autobiographie die
heißt mein Leben als Dagobert nach sechs
Jahren und vier Monaten in der
Justizvollzugsanstalt Plötzensee kommt
er am 13 August 2000 wegen guter Führung
frei und damit beginnt sein zweites
Leben Funke zeichnet Karikaturen für die
Satire Zeitschrift Eulenspiegel und er
tritt als Satiriker auf
vor allem aber heiratet er noch einmal
gleich nach der Entlassung gibt der Elke
Tochters Jawort sie ist Sozialarbeiterin
und die bekannte eines Freundes Funke
hat sie noch in der Haftzeit auf
Freigang in einem Café kennengelernt
wildes erstes Date würde ich sagen und
jetzt könnte es für den Rest des Lebens
still Umarmung werden aber nun geschieht
das was wir auch bei Schauspielerin
Ingrid van Bergen schon erlebt haben
Arno Funke alias Dagobert folgt dem Ruf
des Geldes ein weiteres Mal und geht im
Januar 2013 ins Dschungelcamp also die
Gage kann schließlich jeder gut
gebrauchen und dass er ein wirksam
Auftritt nicht heute hat er ja mit
seinem Buch und den satirische auch
schon bewiesen also Funke ist jetzt im
Dschungel und lässt sich davon den mit
Campern klodell Deckert und Silvia
Gonzales befragen cloudel fragt
wie bist du denn auf die Idee gekommen
hattest du Geldprobleme
Arno antwortet Geldprobleme nein
ich weiß nicht ob du es schon
mitbekommen hast ich hatte ziemlich
schwere Depressionen damals und war kurz
vor dem Selbstmord ich lag schon im Bett
und hatte von meinem Arbeitskollegen
eine 765er gekauft und die hatte ich
schon durchgeladen und in Sicherheit an
der Schläfe ich wollte nicht mehr ich
hatte keine Kraft mehr ich wollte
irgendwie aus der Mühle mit arbeiten und
Geld verdienen raus dann kam mir die
Idee mit der Erpressung das hat mir dann
noch mal so einen Motivationsschub
gegeben mir war klar wenn du das jetzt
nicht machst
dann bleibt er nichts anderes übrig als
dich umzubringen das ist schon hart
dieser Aussage aber also ich kann es
nachvollziehen ich glaube jeder der
schon mal so ein Durchhänger hatte oder
richtige Depression Burnout der kann
komplett mitfühlen was er sich dachte
und das als einfachen Ausweg gesehen hat
und alle seine Probleme sind weg aber
ich meine Überfälle und Erpressungen
statt Therapie
kann nicht die richtige Weg sein ja auf
gar keinen Fall
na gut also Funke wurde am 10 Tag der
Show raus gewesen er musste laut
Zeitungsberichten danach seine Gage von
40.000 € sogar an Karstadt weitergeben
weil er den noch Geld geschuldet hat und
es gab danach auch noch Streit mit RTL
weil er von der dschungelsprecher Stimme
als gefährlicher Verbrecher bezeichnet
wurde mittlerweile ist Funke 73 Jahre
alt im letzten Interview mit Bild im
Jahr 2020 gab er sich ganz glücklich und
erzählte wie gut er mit Kunst verdient
ja aber ehrlich so ein Leben hätte er
auch ohne diese ganze erpressungssache
haben können sicher sein Dagobert Ruhm
so fragwürdig der auch ist der hat ihm
am Anfang bestimmt geholfen
ich bin ehrlich gesagt froh dass nicht
jeder kreative Kopf auf dieser Welt
direkt Bombenanschläge startet nur um
sage ich jetzt mal die Karriere ein
bisschen zu pushen man kann ihn
natürlich eine gewisse Sympathie nicht
absprechen als ich mit seiner
Intelligenz und seinem Einfallsreichtum
und auch später mit seinem Auftreten in
der Öffentlichkeit ja nicht gerade wie
der abartige fiese Bösewicht präsentiert
aber auch wenn er es nicht darauf
angelegt hat so hatte es doch in Kauf
genommen dass Menschen ernsthaft
verletzt werden oder vielleicht sogar
getötet werden aber ich kann mir
vorstellen ich möchte noch nicht in
Schutz nehmen ich kann mir vorstellen
dass er so in seinem Sein düsteren
Strudel von Depressionen und
Suizidalität drin war dass ihm das
wirklich als einzige realistische
Lösungen vorgekommen ist so als sein
Ausweg und er vielleicht gar nicht
darüber nachgedacht hat dass er damit
anderen Menschen massiv Schaden kann bzw
sie sogar umbringen könnte na vielleicht
hatte sich es auch nur schön geredet
dass er zu sich selber gesagt hat okay
ich versuche mit den Bomben meinen
Forderungen und Nachdruck zu verleihen
aber habe jetzt ja nicht vor Leute
irgendwie dabei zu zu töten oder zu
verletzen und hat sich das meiner
Meinung nach damit vielleicht ein
bisschen schön gedacht schön geredet und
hat ganz eindeutig dann versucht diese
Depression halt nur mit sich selber
auszumachen und das war vielleicht für
ihn kreativer weg da rauszukommen aber
ja klar kann natürlich so nicht
funktionieren
na gut Mirko das war's für heute wir
haben uns das meiste am Recherche aus
dem Archiv von Bild ziehen können
spannend waren dabei besonders die
Stücke von Ulf Rosinen über die Arbeit
der Ermittler und Markus Hellwig über
Funkes Sohn hilfreich auch die Timeline
die der NDR auf seiner Homepage hat den
Link dazu den haben wir euch in die Show
Notes gepackt Stefan Netze Band Aufnahme
und schnitt Toni heuer brustproduktion
Wake world Studios München wir danken
euch fürs zuhören und freuen uns wenn
ihr auch beim nächsten Mal dabei seid
euer Mirko und eure Tour